The other day, when my husband and I were talking about our childhood
favorite candies, he mentioned that he was obsessed with Jolly Ranchers,
but he hasn't had them in a while,
so I decided to make him some today.
His favorite flavors are apple and watermelon,
so that's what we went with.
I started by combining some water,
sugar, and corn syrup.
Brought that to 310 degrees,
and then I added in my watermelon extract,
some malic acid, some pink color.
This is the stage where I had to work very quickly
because my mixture began to harden.
So I poured that into my silicone molds
before moving on to my second flavor,
which was green apple. So I added some apple extract,
malic acid,
and green color this time before pouring it into my remaining molds.
After about an hour and a half to two hours,
my Jolly Ranchers had hardened,
so I popped them out and transferred them over to a bowl.
These are so nostalgic to him,
so I was really excited for him to try.
I ended up preferring the apple ones
where he preferred the watermelon ones,
but before the day was over, the bowl was gone.